thank you so much okay I will do my
utmost to be as short as possible but I
have a few words I want to share with
you first of all you are Royal Highness
mr. president your excellences dear
students thank you all for attending and
sorry for the delay and I also want to
thank the library for hosting this event
and of course most important I want to
thank you immanuel for being here you
are a true friend of Denmark men are
born and remain free and equal in rights
these are the very first words in the
Declaration of the Rights of the Man and
of the citizen Britain in Paris during
the French Revolution more than 200
years ago a declaration composed by
brave souls based on the ideals of
enlightenment and adopted in time of
change division and uncertainty mr.
president your visionary countrymen left
us with a priceless legacy looking at
the world today changed the vision and
uncertain sea seems to occur once again
from the east aggressive axis who claim
to be Democrats but act like autocrats
not only in their own countries but in
other countries as well from the south
fanatics who claim to speak and fight on
behalf of a world religion but end up
taking it as a harsh hostage in a fight
they will never win and to the West most
recently our friends and allies in the
land of the free
suddenly striving for less free trade
and discarding international agreements
on trade and climate and human rights so
ladies and gentlemen I think time has
come time has come to ask ourselves what
kind of world do we want what kind of
values do we cherish hateful speech or
peaceful dialogue further divisions or
lasting unity dark fear or big dreams I
know what I believe in but the past has
proven that the dark sides of humanity
always lie and wait and that the shining
European values cannot be taken
for granted the present shows us that
the strongholds of freedom and democracy
are more fragile than we imagined and
looking into the future I fear that
Europe might be the last voice of reason
so you could ask who takes the lead when
it comes to free trade who takes the
lead when it comes to international
agreements who takes the lead when it
comes to humanitarian assistance and
development date who takes the lead when
it comes to data security and consumer
safety and answers Europe does so if we
want our European values to prevail we
must stand up for them and we must stand
together and this is also the case when
it comes to one of the biggest
challenges of our time climate change a
challenge so big that it can only be
handled if we change the way our society
work produce and consume a challenge so
peak that no country can handle it alone
so what we need is Europe European
cooperation European determination and
the vision to act for the benefit of all
of mankind not only a certain kind of
man so like you have said mr. president
there is no planet B and that is true
but it's also a fact that we can in fact
save the planet if we work together and
this is one reason why I believe
European unity is important today as it
has ever been and this is why I insist
even though it's difficult on debating
how our union can improve like we do
today in my mind the Union should be
influential on transnational issues such
as climate trade migration exchange of
ideas for instance it is indeed a great
idea which is to will which will benefit
all of you personally and also benefit
our societies that students are able to
travel and start in universities all
over Europe on the other hand the Union
should not interfere on issues that each
member state can handle alone such as
social systems health care primary
education or and other issues which
belong at nationally
but most important of all the Union must
be the people's Union relevant for the
people wanted by the people because in
the end it is nothing by the people
breaks its and I will shortly close my
remarks but but brexit is a set reminder
of what happened what happens when
positions
despite facts make Europe a scapegoat
for everything that Europe is not strong
because we agree on anything on
everything it's strong because we also
accept to disagree in a civilized way
and because we find peaceful solutions
to our common challenges the goal has
never been to overcome to become one
people but should be many people's
United in diversity so ladies and
gentlemen we live in time of chains and
division but the answer to division is
never to build walls or always putting
your own country first the answer is to
build bridges to put freedom to put
responsibility and dialogue first and I
hope that we who are gathered here today
will share that experience as well so I
look very much forward to a good debate
debate thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much fantastic the author
of the little prince once wrote in life
they are no solutions
they are forces on the move create them
and solutions follow quote unquote so
Misha Lee president now will look very
much forward to the forces you want to
create in Europe the floor is yours and
thank you very much for coming thanks
very much
you're wile anus mr. prime minister the
alas commissioner dear friends ladies
and gentlemen thanks very much for being
here and I mean I like the support nity
to have a direct discussion on Europe
and especially with your generation I
was created by another generation of the
founding fathers experienced war that
divided Europe and what they created is
something absoultely unique it never
happens to have 70 years more than 70
years without any war on this continent
it's unique we never experienced that
before and they created something which
is for the very first time was not based
on a Germany because it's not the unity
of Europe on the basis of the domination
of one nation on the others but a
constant and permanent dialogue between
equal member states this is European
Union it's a unique creation service no
other region in the world whereas this
kind of creation exists no other and
progressively decade after decades
probably we forgot this I mean the
energy of the originals and for your
generation war seems to be something
which could happen far from your country
but there's not a reality of your
day-to-day life here and a lot of these
basics and the roots of this European
Union is less vivid than for the
founding fathers
but but we need this Europe and probably
your generation much more than the
former ones first because we have a
series of huge challenges and your Prime
Minister their last you described part
of them and I fully concur with your
introduction but if you look at the
situation we are in our globalization is
in the huge crisis and this crisis is
mirrored in a big European crisis crisis
because of the race of new challenges
and because of the inability of this
globalization press I precisely to
monitor its own consequences we have a
huge demographic crisis in Africa with
direct impact on Europe
but in the eastern world in America as
well when you look at the situation
between Mexico and the US everywhere in
the world we have a demographic issue
due to birth rates lack of education
creating migration and political crisis
between the different versions you have
a huge environment and climate crisis
because of the consequences of our
current globalization and the indirect
effects of it it's a way to produce
which will force us to create a new way
to produce a new way to organize
ourselves and you have a huge
technological and digital challenge
totally disrupting the way to produce
but as wolves a way to consume to behave
yourself
and to create your new environment and
artificial intelligence is part of this
new revolution with a lot of
consequences and we can revert on it
during the discussion and probably you
fourth challenge dealing with
inequalities because this word based on
short term cycles acceleration of
innovations finance all the concentrated
successes in
one small part of the world and created
some regions in big difficulties and
created increased sandy qualities within
our societies and between societies
these four challenges are putting our
democracies at risk all our democracies
were based on a sort of firm consensus
where we had protection of liberties and
individual rights values rights of the
individual progress for middle classes
and a social free-market
everything is being put at risks because
of the fact that middle classes have no
new opportunities in this environment
and because of this overall crisis and
that's why what we are seeing is the
raise of illiberal democracies of the
oppressors new regimes and twenty years
ago in front of you people like us
probably would have spoken about the end
of history the fact that peace will be
spread out of the world and that
democracies will win the body but even
now within Europe it's no more the case
because of this crisis and Europe is a
way to address these challenges
neither Denmark nor France will fix the
inequality issue the climate issue or
the demographic issue the technologic
issue I mean it's impossible on this
items China and us are proposing the
whole I mean they're models they're role
model totally different but Europe is
the unique continent to have a certain
checks and balances I would say
attachment to liberty attachment to
equality into some time and attachment
to culture education and a series of
values which made ourselves if we don't
decide
to create a new momentum for Europe what
will happen other people big cooperates
other powers will decide for ourselves
in order to try to fix this issues also
will lose the battles on these critical
challenges and this path I want to
propose and the project we can have for
Europe and the European Union is to try
to make our European Union or all model
to fix these four challenges let's
create a new power in order to educate
our people a new pour of development
visit the Africa with new noodle with
Africa let's create the most innovative
region of the world in order to fix the
climate issue it's about renewables
about co2 pricing but a lot of other
issues we can revert them let's create
the leader of artificial intelligence
and technology it's feasible in Europe
if we don't do so it will be created in
the US by large corporates without any
state regulation or by Chinese with
actual regulations but not exactly owls
and the same relationship with
individual liberty freedom and privacy
and let's create a Europe with social
environmental and tax convergence an
actual economic and social poor which
could be the whole model in order to
make this world sustainable these issues
are not just our internal issues it's
part of the domestic debate in Denmark
it's exactly the same in France what we
have to propose for the upcoming
European elections but what we have to
propose more widely is precisely this
big chant for Europe this is not a way
to manage or monitor our european union
your generation will be a generation of
new funding vessels there is no other
choice because the word is at a
crossroad
so let's do it and we can revert on all
these challenges and all the solutions
in detail we propose and I would like to
promote but what I just wanted to focus
on and highlight for this introduction
is that there is no choice you didn't
decide to be here now but your
generation we will have to deal with a
very critical moment of our world my
conviction is that this moment will push
us to decide to take some risks some
time to take some very bold decisions
but the main risk is not to take anyone
the main risk is to accept the authors
to decide for all souls that's why I do
believe that Europe we will have to
invent for the coming month and years is
based on the one we have but has to be
in depth reinvented with a lot of
ambition with a lot of energy and with
our commitment thanks very much
I'm not 100% sure that we'll be able to
touch but all the points that you both
mentioned but let's try at least sort of
to have a good start let's move right
down here I see young lady yes please
set up thank you so much for being here
and taking your time too we can ask our
questions my name is Emily and I'm a
student here at the Copenhagen
University where I studied political
science
I was wondering yesterday you told your
ambassadors that Europe could know what
angle I rely on us for its security and
recently the German Foreign Minister
said that we need to form a
counterweight to Washington because of
the cooling you US relations so now that
you're in Denmark how do you see our
opportunities as a small state to to act
on this to strengthen strengthen our
ties to the EU and to German and friends
without stepping on Trump's toes and
making making him leave NATO or making
our security more risky so yeah how do
we act in this new world order or
disorder maybe hold that thought because
now we go to say the ball and here we
have Cecilia called Sampson and she
would like to ask a question about
brexit do you think there's going to be
a domino effect with other countries
leaving the EU after brexit so now we
have how do we react towards the US and
avoid stepping on president Trump's toes
and we have breaks it and we have
another question over here yes please
yeah if you don't stand up then we have
the microphone mr. president and mr.
prime minister
Marshall aunty Lugosi my name is Tina
I'm sorry I study French I had to say in
French at University of Copenhagen and
and now I am in
intercultural market studies in the
master and and actually I did my
bachelor project on your Saban speech so
I've heard you say a lot you can be
French and you can be well European or I
guess it could be Danish and European
for my case I would like to ask a
question about how can you facilitate a
common European meeting point between
all these different identities without
compromising our national identities
I think identity is a key thing in
making the future Europe so thank you
thank you much and then I say yes peace
lady in a loon wonderful jacket almost
like like a loaf yeah whatever yeah
Roger
Thank You mr. president mr. prime
minister I have a prayer I have a
question for you we should replace it on
I was actually in your hometown M young
this summer where I saw little phones
and I remember that it was very very hot
else it has been very very hot here in
Denmark this summer so my question is
about climate change and you write in
your book that evolution that climate
change is one of the most important
issues of our times to to tackle and you
just mentioned it as well in your speech
so I would like to know starting with
yourself what have you and your wife
done at home in order to become more
climate-friendly and second of all what
do you see as the biggest challenge on
the global scene in order to do
something about climate change
thank you I think we have enough on our
plate here so climate change national
identity brexit and United States who
would like to go first
please please you don't have to answer
all of them please because we have
another sort of see this watch approach
I would try to to attend sir at least
part of the questions ask for a defense
issue and our relationship with with US
and European defense I think your
country is a great country in terms of
defense this morning I pay tribute to
your soldiers and when you convert your
population to the people you lost on the
battleground in Afghanistan so Moses I
mean it's incredible and you pay the
tribute and I think and we had this
discussion at the last NATO meeting when
you when you speak about contribution to
defensive force I think it's it's
incorrect just speak about money we
speak about our people our soldiers and
your soldiers were part of the defaults
and what we did and what we are doing in
Mali today and sale in Afghanistan and
some of the places that's a very first
one you are here and you're part of this
European difference now I'm deeply
convinced we have to do more the
European level we've just passed a law
in France in order to increase our
reports and go to the to person GDP no
because NATO asked for the two percent
GDP it was a commitment I took visa fees
of French people because I think in this
current environment with a huge
technical technological change with new
threats with stories threats we have
radically to be better organized and
invest in a new generation for our
defence and I I do believe that this
kind of effort has to be made at the
European level i I believe in NATO and I
think it's very useful and important but
NATO was created during the Cold War and
there is no more the best enemy I mean
what pushed us and triggered the
creation of NATO is no more here USSR is
no more here you have Russia but we
don't have the same relationship with
Russia
so obviously NATO is useful with
new risks but the implicit deal between
European member European countries in
the US which is de facto us was paying
and was protecting Europe is probably
less valid today than during the Cold
War which means that Europe need this
wake-up call and Europe needs a natural
autonomy and actual independence an
actual sovereignty from a difference
point of view that's why we took a
series of decisions at the European
level during the past year in order to
create new cooperation a newfound and
now a new initiative and Denmark joined
this initiative which is part of this
new European sovereignty in terms of
defense and for me it's not something
against the US absolutely not it's
something for us we need it and we need
it as well to be credible vis-a-vis the
US so I think is very important and the
more we can contribute you have this
opt-out issue it's something to be
debated from a domestic point of view
this is a sovereign issue for you but I
think so you the decision you took in
the framework already are very clear and
very strong and very important to me in
such a context as for breaks it's I
think if we don't want it up properly
breaks it we can have a domino effect
one of our obsession and one of our top
priority is first to respect the vote of
British voters obviously but in the same
time to respect all the other citizens
of the rest of Europe we didn't decide
to kill the European Union so which
means we have absolutely to avoid any
Domino effects which means we have to
preserve our Four Freedoms and the
Solidarity of the Four Freedoms we have
to preserve the integrity of the single
market and the European Union and for me
it's part of the common position we have
together and today we have a very good
organization we discussed among 27s but
we have one negotiator on one common
position precisely to avoid it
your question about identities is a very
important one I'm a strong believer in
Europe but I never defended the idea
that there is in a certain way a sort of
European people making disappear the
National people it doesn't exist and
when you look at the global situation
today you have a reservation elide
entities and identities of people but
I'm deeply convinced that our actual
identity pasta nation French but it's
true for the rest of Europe it's not
just a national identity
we are always an already both Danish and
French and European it's true
through some personal lives and stories
and not you have a beautiful case with
the royal family in this country this is
not totally a Danish story but it's true
for everybody the actual damage doesn't
exist it's already European and it's
true for French people and let me give
you some of the way to embody in a
certain way this reality you have
Erasmus European experience you have
European universities we were discussing
about that and universities applied for
a European program to be part with
Montpellier Dublin and some others of a
European program which is European
experience but even your language is not
just Danish it's part of the European
language European language is not
Esperanto and not English whatever we
are doing now just continue just can you
go on European language in Umberto Eco
had this very beautiful sentence is
translation and there is no actual
French people without the way to
speak in other languages and there is no
actual European language being totally I
would say closed and blocked in his home
language Europe is made by this
exchanges and interactions there was a
very beautiful writer of the 18th
century in France Madame de Stael and
she wrote several novels and one book
called the Lealman and she spoke very
well German and a lot of other languages
and she had this very beautiful formula
saying when I don't find a word in
French I'm sure to find it in German or
in English and that's exactly the
European story and that's why I do
believe that what you are doing what we
are doing is just to say we have a
national identity we have even a family
identity but this identity because we
are European is not just a national one
there is no look at the map there is no
other region in the world with such a
diversity of languages of people of
diversity and climate change and I have
to say we are doing some investment at
the Elysee Palace because now we are
there but before joining we made an
investment in the house for Windows
precisely in order to reduce the
electricity costs well climate change no
but because it's I mean and that's how
to reconcile climate and economy as for
for me is the most important global
challenge its co2 emission I mean
obviously you have biodiversity oceans
and so on but you ask me for one co2
emission which means on mobility and
companies on our way to produce
electricity we have to make a big change
and satisfy Sergey we are - we are
dealing at a national level
hiding too close all the coal plants
which is number one source of emission
the big mobility plan and we increase
surprise for gasoline which is not very
popular I can tell I can tell you but
it's a necessity that's what we have to
do now at the European level with the
co2 pricing an actual single market and
at the global level it's part of the
climate change the time at Paris
agreement but that form is a very top
one because that's the origin of
precisely what you experience during
your summer in amia and and in
Copenhagen with this new temperatures
and by the way I'm happy you you saw the
Tour de France in amia and I'm happy to
to see in the coming years the Tour de
France in Copenhagen
[Applause]
well I think I would leave into myself
so a few comments will the be a domino
effect after breaks if that's exactly
the same question and the very first
question raised by Thomas from when I
first met him in the White House like
and I couldn't really figure out whether
he was hopeful or but-but-but-but my
answer was a clear no but I agree with
the manual it obviously linked to the
way we deal with this and and and and
the solution and that's just an
additional reason why we have to strike
a balance between obligations and and
and and right so to speak I do not fear
a domino effect because if you look to
UK these days it is obvious that they
are starting to suffer from it and I'm
pleased to say that if you ask the Danes
they are more pro-europe now than before
the referendum I think breaks it is a
reminder of what we have taken for
granted 10% of the Danish TVP is
directly linked to our participation in
the signal market so I mean there's no
way we should leave the European Union
but at the same time we have to say
seriously what you asked about about
national identity and that's why I'm in
favor of striking a balance where we use
the European Union to solve big problems
and where we leave small things to
nations we need this kind of what how
should I put it a peaceful competition
between countries I mean we haven't
solved all problems in Denmark but but I
mean the Scandinavian model have been
successful in many ways for instance in
your opening remarks
immanuel you talked about the fact that
inequality could lead to a situation
where people turn their backs towards
globalization and of course we have
issues endemic as well but I think we
have been together with Sweden and other
countries better than many other
countries to redistribute prosperity
among ourselves and and for that reason
the Danes are organ towards the rest of
the world and through towards changes so
I think we should
we should and that would be an ongoing
discussion and we will disagree and we
will agree and we have to find a
compromise because we shouldn't you know
leave everything to Europe and and and
on the other hand we should understand
that sovereignty is not about taking all
decisions by yourself that's a balance
and then just a few words about NATO and
and and and and defense I mean we need
this debate in Denmark and that's why I
have called for this debate we both
witnessed summit the NATO summit a few
months ago
few weeks ago I'm not the one who should
give all the details about our internal
discussions but I just want to say that
I share your opinion that participation
is not only about how much money to
spend also about your readiness to stand
up and at least I used the opportunity
to tell the American president in in a
very clear voice that we will not accept
that we are judged only by our
expenditures I mean we have had exactly
as many casualties in Afghanistan as the
Americans and we always stand up so
that's not acceptable but we have to
realize that this is not only about
Trump of course Trump put it his way and
slightly different from what we have
experienced in the past but there's a
reason why he was elected and I think we
have to take seriously that u.s. in
general expect that we take a great
responsibility for our own security so
that's why I define NATO as a
cornerstone but at the same time we have
to do more in the European framework we
have this opt-out and it can't be moved
without a referendum and not calling for
a referendum today but we have to
discuss it and in the meanwhile with
full respect of the opt-out Denmark need
to participate in a European framework
as well and that's why we have closed
this deal or agreed that we should
enhance our pilots well cooperate
and I don't think that will provoke the
American president quite the opposite
actually because they actually demand
from us that we do more so if we respond
by doing more there's no reason why this
would react in a negative way thank you
very much time is running out
unfortunately but I have a question here
from suitable basically asking both of
you and if you could do it snappy way
sort of how can we improve the
cooperation on migration between our two
countries
migration being obviously very important
issue also if you want to have a Europe
that protects one minute each is that
possible I will win you 30 of my seconds
no look migration is a challenge not
just for these euros eager to come but
for decades first point second we need
to articulate responsibility and
solidarity so the way to proceed is not
to be simplistic or nationalistic no
issue on a national basis is sure and
look at the nationalistic approach what
they propose is against the order but
they never manage to coordinate between
each choses so what we have to do better
cooperation and more development with
origin country especially in Africa more
cooperation against smugglers with
transit countries what we launched one
year ago birth with some of them more
investment on our common protection
common frontiers with context what we
propose nice input data reorient sense
common Organization for countries of
arrivals with more solidarity with these
control centers and and and solidarity
distinction between asylum and economic
migration as einem is a duty no
discussion economic migration is to be
discussed and some people have to come
back and six common regulation to have
solidarity between the other member
states between origin country and the
others not on the basics of Cota because
Qatar doesn't fly but basics on
willingness approach for those who can
get as
financial contribution throw up some of
this country's but a common regulation
and you do me a favor you just say you
agree yeah right thank you very much
mister because time is running out and I
have people here looking very sort of
strict at me and you know it's your turn
so basically I agree
thank you very much mr. Hyman good
[Applause]
I can't let you leave mister press it up
keep you here anyway but you have to
leave and but I have to shift thank you
to me I wish some debate should arrive
you have all the European Council meet
yeah basically I wanted to give you a
present and we thought about giving you
an umbrella when we watch the World Cup
ceremony in Moscow but then I know sort
of your colleague here so he is
obviously made sure that you have an
umbrella if it rains so we decided upon
something else we started with so here
we go and now we will go full circle
when you came to the Royal Library you
saw the original manuscripts of Sir Hugo
so let's also end with certain cuticle
so this is sarong cubicle so please
accept so a cubicle as a present from
the library the University of Copenhagen
and the artist high Heights and remember
and I pursue this goes for Presidents
and Prime Minister's life can only be
understood backwards but it must be
lived forwards thank you very much for
coming mr. president
[Applause]